[Musique]
là
oh
d oh
[Musique]
tricoter
zorn bigard
précis les jeux
donner
ce n'était que le château elle
il est temps de mon temps dans ce délai
donné
je ne peux pas
copé
est votre souhait
tu étais vivant
à la chapelle enfants
candidat
demain
des fois je me dis en face en typhon
ça va
c'était le cas vous
gagnerez
rien
visages étaient graves mais ton sourire
pied
j'ai marché doit être signé
[Applaudissements]
tu feras
ce que je fais
je suis bien
[Musique]
oui
ah ah
hahaha
qu'est-ce que vous agace le plus qu on
vous surnomme bigoudis à cause de votre
calvitie qu'on imite mauvaise imitation
ou alors que stéphane collaro me
transforme en crabe rien de plus qu'un
ami elie aboud agace ou rien du tout on
pourra jc bien bon écoutez je le trouve
plus ou moins réussies séjour du public
qui doit réagir sur l'animal placé voire
à une opinion mais sam ongeri pourquoi
voulez vous que ça méritait krasucki
chéché collaro vous trouvez comment
d'après ce que j'ai compris il a voulu
présenter un un prolo un métallo
parisien type prime à memni un mégot
alors une foule n'a pas d'importance
puis c'est tout pour le reste basse
c'est son affaire lui est publique et
bigoudis mon pâtissier ce sont les bons
journée beaucoup de surnombres de la vie
dans lesquels maintenant
à deuxième surnom très vite comme ça à
chaud venu vous avez vu la une du matin
à paris la semaine dernière vont parler
du look de la cgt alors quand on lisait
l'article on s'apercevait que c'était
juste une manchette de journalistes
qu'est ce que vous pourriez pas que le
look krasucki c'est à dire le côté un
peu voyeur comme ça la casquette est ce
qu'on va y pas que cela peut décourager
certaines professions de des cadres des
professeurs de s'engager de de militer à
la cgt ce que vous croyez pas vous
donner à l'essai était finalement un
look un peu trop pro
l'aubance pas bonne et socialement lou
volo contre je suis comme je suis je
suis la cgt fera même pas à une personne
n'y a ni à son allure on a la tête qu'on
a et non il ya l'image qu'on fabrique
puis à la réalité des personnes et de
l'organisation
vous me parliez de du matin de paris
c'était un titre incorrect le soir elles
ont dépassé la route des personnes
exclues oui mais ça n'était pas innocent
et c'est
pas une affaire de justice j'ai réagi en
protestant
le matin de paris après la protestation
je tiens à me faire respecter et à faire
respecter l'organisation que je
reprenant non pas pour en revenir à
votre question s'agissant de la
diversité des salariés je me sens
représentation du monde du travail tel
qu'il est je pensais aussi un truc pour
empêcher une telle catégorie sociale
quand je me trouve que j'ai souvent
l'occasion de rencontrer des ingénieurs
des cadres supérieurs des crises ya bien
sûr les scientifiques je visite jeudi ce
quiz nous le comprenons et ils n'ont pas
l'impression de parler à un extra
terrestre je vous arrête c'est positif
je vous donne trois minutes et vous
allez essayer de le convaincre de
rentrer à la cgt
vous avez trois minutes comme dit bout
vous êtes une salariée
qui vous arrive il peut vous arriver
d'avoir durant le défendre vos intérêts
dont salariés
salaire avancement sécurité l'emploi
dignité aussi
vous avez besoin
d'être organisé tout seul il peut vous
arriver de vous désiriez l'importance et
syndicales et on est d'accord mais
pourquoi l'association j'y viens mais
d'abord d'abord l'idée c'est de se
regrouper alors pourquoi le sait la cgt
mais parce que
citez moi un seul visage plus combatif
que la cgt
plus proche des préoccupations des gens
tout nus ferme dans les discussions avec
des patrons il a l'aspect d'un futur
elle a pu sorte de défaut n'est en tout
cas
essayer de la semaine et sinem ne vous
convient pas et bien contribué à le
faire comme vous voudriez qu'ils soient
mais ne restez pas seul parce que comme
salarié vous êtes en fait respectivement
la jeunesse
si vous commencez à faire engager mes
salariés la cgt sabine est très mal pour
moi là bas je veux seulement quand on me
faut ce qu'ils sont là je demande une
augmentation de
grâce à ça c'est comme un rêve c'est
convaincant c'est cette fois ci
maintenant je voulais une question
d'image et écoutez moi je vis je veux
venir moi je ne cherche pas comme sien à
convaincre milan ac je veux donner
décharge richir fait alors écoutez moi
fait partie des gens qui pensaient que
le bilan des pays de l'est est
globalement positif
vous avez participé en septembre 86 à
berlin-est et une réunion de la fsm de
temps peut réconcilier un conte vélo 11e
on peut réconcilier avec eux et vous
vous êtes maintenant et des
vice-présidents de la fsm en compagnie
de roumains de bulgares de cech de
russes et d'allemands de l'est aux yeux
de beaucoup d'hôtels et d'acides gras la
question est ce que vous mangez krasucki
aujourd'hui vous vivriez dans un pays de
l'est avaient d'abord je suis français
oui bon alors moi j'aime bien vivre
henry d'accord sur tout alors parce que
ce genre de questions vous voyez ça n'a
pas beaucoup de sens ah non moi je vis
en france et je par contre j'ai une
certaine idée de comment on pourrait
vivre mieux en france et reed est devenu
en france c'est un peu se rapprocher des
pays arabes a même pas du tout on peut
pas au sens de copier ce qui se fait
dans tel terme aubry notant qu'il s'agit
il ya ya certaines choses à sainté reste
certaines choses m'intéressent c'est
peut-être son vainqueur car
fondamentalement non je trouve qu'il ya
des injustices et des inégalités
sociales comme les six avaient bien reçu
un énorme il n'ya pas communiste qui le
disent il ya ainsi l'économie qui disent
que tout le monde devient alors le vrai
partage et je pense donc je considère
que telle qu'elle est cette société a
besoin d'être changé et a fait mener à
la française ils ont une fonction de
notre histoire de la manière de vivre
des français et c'est tout à fait autre
chose mais mais vous ne me ferez pas
sous prétexte qu'on sait déjà qu'un
espoir de faire changer d'avis et tel ou
tel défaut
renoncé à comprendre ce qui se passe
d'important dans ces pays de ce qui s'y
est passé là bas si je prends l'union se
dire
qu'elle a fait il ya 70 ans c'est
l'équivalent à notre siècle de ce que la
révolution française l'a fait il ya deux
chiens cancer oui poser une question
définitive ça sera la dernière et
j'aimerais qu'on me répondiez le plus
franchement possible
vous avez eu le malheur pendant la
guerre d'être déportés
aujourd'hui en urss on n'est pas sans
savoir qu'il existe des camps de
concentration comment pouvez vous serrer
la main de ces gens là vous savez quand
l'urss les juifs n'ont pas droit de
sortir du rss comment pouvez vous serrez
la main ce journal
pouvez-vous me poser des questions il
est un jeu on a vu aussi peu
raisonnable parce que non aujourd'hui ça
existait mais aujourd'hui en urss il
n'ya laxiste pas qu'aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui il y a parce qu'ils n'ont
pas eu non plus en plus de prison ils
ont un système pénitentiaire qui est
basé sur des camps de travail ils disent
que c'est pour une rééducation mais ça
concerne des gens est prisonnier de
droit commun ils n'ont pas de
prisonniers politiques il y en a eu nous
avons que vous dites aujourd'hui à
l'épisode y analyse nous avons protesté
sinon est ce qu elles sont en train de
régler ces messieurs et vous le savez
des réformes sur lui en union soviétique
en ce moment notamment sur la question
des droits de l'homme y compris sur la
liberté de circulation des juifs ou de
tout autre c'est que les juifs en effet
c'est mes jeux comme elle l'est refusent
d qui n'a pas droit de sortir justement
je suis en train de vous dire cette
question qui nous a amenés à critiquer à
discuter alors dire mais pour pourquoi
vous laissez pas ces gens circuler sorti
un cd aujourd'hui c'est en cours de
règlement vous pensez que j'entends du
bruit mais ces points seulement je pense
pas que c'est parce que seulement nous
avons donné notre avis nous avons joué
un rôle et utile justement à une époque
où on nous reprochait de ne ne pas crier
nous avons dit qu'il fallait
publiquement quand c'était nécessaire au
lycée à bien c'est en train de changer
sérieusement et personne ne le conteste
dans les milieux de la formation j'ai
grand jour alors une surprenez par votre
question parce que parce que c'est là
que les gens comme un vos collègues oms
comment sont en train de devenir prudent
oui tant pis pour eux ça s'appelle lutte
gréco romaine mais ça vient d'égypte et
sa date de 2002 avant jésus-christ parmi
ces quatre lutteurs il y à patrice
mourier champion du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
franck tous les lois pose pas la
question j'essaie mais enfin tout faux
pas la lui poserez je m'ennuie mais pour
le britannique
il ya beaucoup d'intérêts golo la
rigolote regardant le chant et la
composition
de la famille
je sois allé je vois la joue une bonne
opération qui réveille avec les
compilations dans la mode oui tu avais
aussi mon corps comme il a travaillé sur
ce même s'il n'a jamais été aussi beau à
une compilation de jazz parce que les
gens se garent la mort le ciel est
maintenant sauver le genre ou
compilation d'urgence avec de vieux
morceaux on se regarde le dire devient
un morceau de jazz john browne quincy
jones jimi smith tout le monde voilà
c'est très très bien fonctionné dans un
souci est le deuxième c'est joe cocker
qui est le biais gaga de tout le monde
connaît pas la voix rock witchu
chaussures la population c'est la
population pour retrouver l'autre 10
septembre 1987 bande minuit passe la
soirée avec cicciolina ou trastevere
pour préparer l'interview destinés à la
première émission
[Musique]
oui
c'est vrai
[Musique]
cet avis
mazerolle et nous serons kaman a collé
seashell au canon mégane à ses symboles
et ça
soudain mon élan à midi tout schéma
travaux non c'est bon bagnato -dès
maguet
galletti
[Musique]
où
pioline outils masturber espèces
c'est ya des concepts est vive à la
masturbation
toutes les deux suspects sous une femme
laureen plastique à
six personnes et la discothèque a
italienne est un qui a des sauts à
l'instar ont battu l'as monaco on a
fallu transporter des crystal home alone
zone
emea chez la verdure
zukin comme à
ses plus
beaux habits ne-yo
l'utilisent espèces au palais des
geishas
etc non de capitaux des balles et
dégagent beaucoup non c'est kito lydiane
nepean celle à 16 soit l'état mais
piacere langue clitoridienne promis
pierre de la mort des colonies
sauvages iman avait
un canal s il
est important de passer l'ami sur l'adsl
masculin noms importants et avait là la
consistance à des faits l'amour des
belles économies
hadja fatou la morricone ou la donne
si aux fantômes non seulement comme la
douane a contenté dans l'ancien quand
certains nostalgiques sand est grande et
les couleurs chaudes comme une gamme
coca cola n'a
évolué qu'à développer de saines cagnoli
bayonne en solo contre ia nimani pino
mollo
merci mme yade
[Musique]
est trop grand
11 décembre 1987 cicciolina est à paris
à partir de ce soir tous les soirs à la
belle époque que karine
[Applaudissements]
mégalo
ce que nous aimons
[Musique]
tous
qu'ils n'ont pas
nous
[Musique]
y à t'il
non
[Musique]
bahia
à mon père teilhard de chardin est un
peu le symbole de la complexité quand on
veut dire que quelque chose est
compliqué on dit c'est du tir de chardin
alors est-ce que vous pouvez en quelques
phrases nous nous résumer ce que
teilhard de chardin rapporté au monde
mais si je dois résumé des liens en
quelques phrases je dirais qu'il a pensé
un système des systèmes de pensée ouais
c'est baroque mais nous avons tous été
élevés dans une culture donnée dans une
ville de visionner et toutes les
religions
biodiversité alors que diarra imaginer
que des systèmes philosophiques à pâques
et de prémisses différentes passons d'un
artiste par de la matière pur un
brahmane part de respect pur et un
chrétien croit apple a pas dire un peu
l'esprit sais pas comment ça colle entre
deux thés hier à imaginer justement une
espèce de kaléidoscope de tous les
systèmes pour faire comprendre qu' on
n'est pas
à ce combat est philosophe si on ne
connaît qu'un système mais le vrai
philosophe c'est celui qui s'est
transposée d'un système dans un autre à
partir donc de culture même absolument
hétérogènes tandis que on sait très bien
qu'un musicien cc pas transposé c'est
pas la musique et de la même façon un
final ce guide ses pas transposer un
système de l'autre à sa sortie ce qui
explique que quelqu'un qui sera mettons
chrétiens 2 fera pour discuter avec un
marxiste accepter de marcher avec le
marxiste à partir des mêmes prémisses
entrer dans le même système lorsqu'on
discute d'une question qui concerne les
affaires matériel alors on demandera de
la même façon a inspiré un marxisme s'il
veut comprendre de l'intérieur est honni
en fait tous les mystiques d'entrer dans
le système des prophètes et des
mystiques alors nous perdions disent que
vous avez découvert finalement c'est que
teilhard de chardin et est très
intéressée par la médiumnité et qu'il
pensait que le christ était le le plus
grand des médiums mais c'est le personne
le sait ça c'est fini parce qu'on a
voulu le cacher on a détruit c'est un
signal à dire tellement ces scandaleuses
on a détruit plus de 15 opuscule de
teilhard qui traitait de ce problème et
je n'ai sauver un seul que j'ai publié
non pas dans des livres mais dans les
fascicules de mona sociation roland
l'universel tellement teyarett de génie
pour saisir les astuces
d'explication des miracles des
phénomènes extraordinaires de la bible
des miracles de la vie des saints à
partir de phénomènes de la mutualité et
l'a étudiée par exemple rapport du
problème du temps une cicatrisation
instantanée dans une guérison tout est
normal sauf le facteur temps stif et ce
qui semble prouver qu'on est entré dans
un système de pensée dans un monde où le
facteur temps est différente en nous
savons comme je suis spécialisé dans les
problèmes de débit hommes de bibendum
bonne cette année nous savons que ce qui
caractérise le médium c'est qu'au niveau
de son optique de son psychisme il est
important d'y remédier sommes que
reculer dans le temps et je met par
exemple au moment où jésus crucifié
passe il est coloré et les stigmatiser
je ne crois pas qu'un stigmatiser soient
stigmatisés parce qu'il est seul je
crois qu'il est stigmatisée parce qu'il
est médium et il est allé se balader du
côté de la crucifixion du christ si l'on
sait qu'à une époque où la science
commencent à s'intéresser de plus en
plus à la vie à la surface il à l'église
dont celle dans ses discours officiel ne
s'était jamais vraiment intéressé c'est
un homme extraordinaire l'église s'est
toujours intéressé à l'imprimeur mais
comme nous a élevés à l'idée avec l'idée
que les égyptiens étaient des paillotes
les brahmanes étaient des païens et
serra en italie évangéliser ce qui était
encore vivant on a échangé et c'est bien
évidemment mais le scandale c'est que
les plus beaux textes sacrés de l'egypte
ne sont absolument pas enseigner alors
qu'on aurait là la matière d'un
catéchisme supérieur car il y a dans des
libres qui sont dans des égyptiens il y
à la résurrection il y à la divinisation
de l'être après la mort tout cela est
éclairé tout cela et lumineux dans les
tongs ou de la vallée des rois si on
veut regarder bizarre c'est pas parce
que ce que vous dites finalement c'est
que le judaïsme c'est inspiré l'egypte
ancienne au mieux christianisme s'est
inspiré du judaïsme et vous vous allez
vers une sorte de religion universelle
oui seulement je reproche au judaïsme
c'est pas sa faute c'est son initiateur
qui avait un peu sponsable il y avait
utilisé comme prince égyptien et donc il
savait des choses qu'il n'a pas
transmises il a fait son intrigue alors
que on ne pourra pas arriver à la
religion ni à celles ci on ne ressources
pas tous à l'egypte au lieu de partir du
décalogue il faut partir des textes qui
sont les inspirations du décalogue au
lieu de partir du sinaï lieu de
convenance pour les byzantins qui ont
conduit le pèlerin là il faut partir du
vrai - aurel qui vient d'être trouvée
tête encore dans ce jeu qui fera l à 100
km au nord d'eilat nous y étions
l'inscription le 28 février dernier ça
bouleverse toutes sortes donné sa
magnifique même la chronologie brise
mais qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout il y fit
la chronologie serait pas davantage
l'importance et comprendre que le
message a été abattu et on n'arrivera
pas à la religion universelle si on n'a
pas le courage de reprendre des choses
du début alors naturellement toute la
journée une réussite et ce ne sont pas
de hiérarchie de ce fait leur éthique
par rapport à bien sûr que je suis
rigoureusement je suis avec bénéfices je
m'en voudrais système équivalent ici
soit pas apparaître les nommer je m'en
voudrais si c'était banal c'est vrai que
vous avez institué une prière dans le
monde entier entre 20h30 et 20h35
sonorisation télérama cet énoncé sein
avancé nous avons lancé ce truc là avec
des amis le faisait depuis très
longtemps et avec le monde entier de la
présence ans avec un vénérable boulistes
nous avons eu l'idée de lancer une
association
de labrihe universel sans inscription et
aux cotisations sauf la brière que vente
am devait tarder à mettre en scène tout
le monde on demande aux gens de briller
pour l'harmonie du monde et pour les
malades que joignent le groupe de briey
l'idée est très bonne et d'ailleurs ça
marche très bien et nous avons
réellement des courriers incroyable de
gens qui s'associent à nous donc nous y
voilà l'universel vient par la base et
non pas par les hiérarchies est ce que
c'est vrai mon père que vous priez pour
le diable on a raconté ça dans un
article de barils personnellement je
crois que le lien mais surtout la
projection mentale de toute la
négativité a donc là l'existence
terrible bon mais dans un texte très
très extraordinaire qui s'appelle de
dialogue avec l'ange il est expliqué que
si nous n'étions c'est une capable de
nous arrêter de penser négatif
instantanément vient de distribuer parce
qu'il aurait plus de nourriture pas et
de toutes nos égalité nos horreur de
méchanceté de terrado guerra si on
arrivait à détruire ce défi du choeur
d'hommes il n'y aurait plus de bien tu
réellement mais il faut dire que là
aussi c'est tout aussi utopique que la
religion universelle on n'est pas encore
prêt est ce que vous croyez mon père
comme
malraux que le xxième siècle sera
spiritualiste ou ne sera pas je crois
que le 21e siècle est le 22e et 23e
parce qu avait pas de raison que ça
s'arrête sera sera de plus en plus
religieux mais vrai simplement tout à
fait différent fait de religion par
rapport à ce qu'on a connu auparavant et
au point que nos ancêtres ne regarderai
pas leurs petits c'est normal
en réalité nous allons vers un type de
religion qui ne sera pas un mélange qui
s'appelle syncrétisme du tout mais alors
que les hiérarchies sont payés
entretenus par leurs coreligionnaires
pour
exagérer leurs particularismes nous
allons vers quelque chose qui sera une
salle d'abord une symbiose vrai un
oecuménisme total pas seulement de
chrétiens sur une rigolade on fera
vraiment dommage y'a bon dont on n'a pas
idée déjà mais on percevra à partir des
spirituels des religions il y aura un
accord au niveau du mystique et c'est de
là que viendra la carte et pour les
autres merci vous savez j'ai retrouvé ce
qu'on a prévoit une forme ans s'est vu
j'ai retrouvé les poubelles de polaroïd
que vous avez fait pas tranché cette
question au festival de cannes c'est la
semaine fier lorsque j'ai regardé de
noir je voudrais bien faire c'était là
faire danser les gardiens
je me souviens maintenant je fais des
photos un dominique issermann bonsoir
soit tu fais quoi paris moi je suis de
faire
m
2 prochaine avec parmi les personnes
encore dominique issermann oui tu
évolues le clip on vient de voir c'était
un type et dominique issermann déjà qui
s'appelait dance to develop et celui là
il va s'appeler comme en
franche comté
alors est ce que tu crois tout l'été à
une certaine époque un phénomène de
société énorme part des livres partez
partez disque est ce que tu crois
qu'aujourd'hui encore quelque chose à
apporter au monde où est ce que tu fais
ça peut payer des impôts autant que je
sache je suis toujours chanteur ouais
tu continues je considérais les
prochains 10 heures quand la fin janvier
à janvier ils s'appellent comme le clip
non c'est un humain amis ont menacé bien
que
j'écoutais merci
c'est dit
brest
alors il ya quoi il ya vingt 20 ans
- au moins
avec john baez dylan peter paul and mary
vous allez voulait changer le monde est
ce que le monde peut changer
à bongo joue pas beaucoup non
on a le temps
et alors il a changé ouais
moi je trouve ce disque est un peu
différent de l'autre et ses îles et plus
plus positive peut-être plus
la musique est peut-être plus percutante
je trouve ça fun évidemment c'est
toujours
proximité avec les autres disent mais je
trouve qu'une petite rupture ce
disque-là par rapport à ceux d'avant est
une espèce d'énergie
d'optimisme comme ça qui
c'est très beau dans les
la fourrure énergie léonard est ce que
tu trouves ton énergie
[Musique]
je n'ai jamais peur d'eux
et la suède
53 quel effet ça fait de
moi je suis vieux mais j'ai 38 ans c'est
pas jeunes non
il paraît que tu veux jamais appelé les
femmes baby c'est vrai
tu appelles baby
ou islamiques issermann tr/min frissonne
déterminée sert ben non taipei qui veut
jamais un téléphone mobile de lucie
ensemble avant mais dans la vie c'est
possible dans la vie non c'est pas
possible
j'ai toujours des maisons grâce à hydra
je le garde je la garde toujours mais
paypal a souvent non
qu'est ce que tu penses que tu vas
laisser de plus important quel morceau
de musique qu'elle l'est plus
je pense que c'est pas de toujours
mai
je ne peux pas choisir un morceau s'il
ya quelque chose d'important se
av est ce que tu crois que tu vas
laisser de plus important c'est ce qui
est le plus connu
à ma mort je pense que c'est donc
suzanne que tu vas laisser plus de temps
probablement et beautiful losers
peut-être
c'est pas mal et un prochain disque est
le prochain disque
alors toi qu'est ce que tu sais bien
je continue à faire les photos m'avaient
et portrait d'un côté 9
la première fois parce que d'habitude il
paraît que tu veux pas tellement que des
photos soient mises dans des ligues soit
tu penses que ça suffit qu'elle soit
dans les magazines pour des pivots pour
du rédactionnel ses enseignes
c'est vrai j'aime bien le support de la
presse est bien français qu'une photo va
dans un bien travaillé pour la page
journal
savoir que ce support est éphémère et
disparaît c'est travailler pour un
support comme un mur de galeries par
exemple sur effrayer jamais osé faire
une exposition
parce que c'est quelque chose qui doit
rester quelques permanents un tirage on
doit vendre
robert mais là je me suis décidé
comment ça se passerait si j'avais fait
un travail de publicité en fait avec des
avec des japonais avec à droite c'était
un calendrier de nus et puis en le
faisant j'ai pensé qu' on n'avait pas
vraiment
tout ce qu'on aurait pu faire dans
château en château de maisons laffitte
première tournée pendant
trois fois et d après midi et j'ai fait
d'autres photos et qui sait après les
contacts se sont accumulés fnath et les
tirages et puis après un éditeur à celle
en or et moselle a vu les photos il a
proposé de faire un livre et ça s'est
enchaîné comme ça mais ce qui s'appelle
anne roy j'ai cherché un terrain de
cette facilité c'est pas c'est
l'histoire d'une fille avec un bras dans
un château c'est en fait c'est un
portrait de m c'est le constat de la
noire
[Musique]
à
vous avez 84 ans ce n'est pas rien et
vous publiez en allemagne en italie en
france en angleterre un livre qui
s'appelle rang français dans trois
semaines chez car la faune amoureuse de
l'amour qui a été un petit peu réécrit
par notre ami dan tva qui est qui est un
livre qui raconte votre ville est assez
extraordinaire faut bien le dire ce qui
justifie que nous soyons venus vous voir
ce soir à munich alors quand on essaye
de comprendre un peu votre personnage
quand on essaye de comparer qui vous
aide à des gens que les gens connaissent
peut-être un petit peu mieux que vous on
pourrait penser à marlene dietrich à
greta garbo et on le verra tout à
l'heure un petit peu eva braun aussi et
si on voulait raconter votre vie en
citant des films on pourrait citer
cabaret on pourrait citer les damnés et
on pourrait citer le dictateur parce que
vous avez très bien connu à la fois
adolf hitler et charlie chaplin donc
vous avez pu assister à des des dîners
avec les dignitaires nazis vous avez pu
finalement vous retrouvez dans ce chalet
en train d'essayer de le corriger le
script des esclaves blanche avec
goebbels vous avez fréquenté leurs
femmes vous avez fréquenté leurs petites
amies et jamais vous n'avez pu obtenir
une information plus précise sur la vie
sexuelle d'hitler
non
les femmes l'admirer l'adoré et
une fois j'étais dans un hôtel est là et
il est repassé elle je sais plus qui
s'était c'était une actrice qui s'est
précipité vers la fenêtre j'ai dit oh
mon dieu notre fureur et moi je pense
que dsk est imbécile et elles prennent
presque pleuré de joie et je ne
comprends vraiment pas et je n'ai déjà
dit tout à l'heure
qu'est ce que c'est et qui a fait que
des femmes réagissent comme ça moi je
comprenais pas mais à ce sujet on a
semblé bien et il voulait être adoré
comme un saint vivez 39 km 40 km de
munich en pleine bavière dans une région
qui finalement depuis la la fin de la
guerre n'a n'a pas complètement changé
et tout le monde le sait est ce que
votre votre attitude de face aux
questions que je viens vous poser est
est ce que vous avez peur de répondre
parce que vous seriez menacée si vous
disiez des choses sur l'époque
aujourd'hui non
bien qu' on ne sait on ne sait jamais on
a bien on a beaucoup de nazis encore et
j'en ai connu quelques-uns avec qui j'ai
discuté à la
maison pour tous une à une excuse
nous sommes voisins
mal
notée par
quelqu'un d'important mais
mon dieu qu'est ce que je fais quand
j'étais jeune six ans je suis entré à
l'écologie côté et je n'ai rien appris
d'autre que d'obéir et le militaire et
lui a été repris par hitler plus grave
et dans une certaine mesure je comprends
lorsque vous aviez 20 ans et que vous
couzier vos pyjamas en soies vous
habitiez chez une charmante dame juive
comme vous dites dans votre livre qui
s'appelait madame rothen stein est ce
que vous savez ce qu'elle est devenue
pendant la guerre non car hésitante les
mavs il ajouté
je les lui ai rendu visite quand même et
bien qu'elle me dise toujours ne venez
plus et un jour on m'a dit elle a été
orthez à ce moment là on ne pouvait plus
faire de recherche on savait ce que ça
voulait dire
c'était une vieille fille vraiment très
charmant d'aimables qui n'avait fait de
mal à personne
est ce que maintenant à 80 ans passés
même si vous le faites pas du tout est
ce que vous regrettez d'avoir été mêlé à
tout ça finalement et ah oui vous avez
toujours vécu dans un grand luxe que ce
soit berlin pendant la guerre ou avant
la guerre que ça soit hollywood est
aujourd'hui finalement vous avez perdu
votre maison de roquebrune cap martin
qui a été
saisie par le gouvernement français à
l'issue de la guerre vous habitez dans
un charmant village enfin dans un
appartement qui n'est pas très grand
alors comment vivez vous aujourd'hui et
surtout de quoi avez vous aujourd'hui
avec quel argent pouvez-vous subsister
aujourd'hui
parfois je me pose la même question
j'ai perdu plus
encore
j'aime à l'éden park
soi-disant amis j'espère quand même tous
mes biens il est parti à l'étranger mais
là j'en ai vendu mal par la suite après
la guerre j'en avais plus rien ou rien
du tout le la ferme été nommé plus
rester à la maison et donc c'était
peut-être ma propre confort qui essayait
de faire à coup tout mon possible g
j'avais toujours pas plus que son sac à
main
et puis toujours et donc ses bijoux
étaient très importants et ans et avec
ses bijoux j'ai pu acheter racheter une
maison
là
est à peu près à 5 qui leur a dit si
vraiment dans un endroit extraordinaire
une très belle villa avec plus de 4000
mètres carrés et j'ai besoin de deux
personnes dans cela donc c'était trop de
travail et
à ce moment là je me suis dit c'est trop
travail je vais m'acheter cet
appartement et ainsi me reste plus de
temps pour mes violon d'ingres
ovadia sofer bonsoir vous êtes
ambassadeur d'israël c'est à dire que
non seulement vous représenter israël en
france et en plus comme on est
ambassadeur de france chaque fois que
vous allez à l'étranger vous êtes
toujours ambassadeurs d'israël oui en
effet j'ai gagné ce titre la dignité de
l'ambassadeur d'israël il ya deux ans
mais je suis ambassadeur depuis 18 ans
en france comme dans l'autre on y
viendra repris vous été en irak d'une
famille bourgeoise assez riche et vous
avez été obligé de fuir l'irak après
guerre en traversant ces marais où
aujourd'hui il ya la guerre non oui
c'est tout un époux belge appartenait à
la communauté juive d'irak league et la
communauté le plus ancien des
communautés juives d'une famille
bourgeoise et puis je me suis trouvé à
l'âge de 15 ans comme
poursuivi pour une clean qui était
considéré dans le temps comme le plus la
plus gande crime qu'on peut commettre
c'était d'apprendre l'hébreu vous avez
été surpris en train d'apprendre
l'hébreu oui j'ai été surpris et puis
j'ai je devais quitter et on a promis à
mon père qui dans le temps a donné une
large somme d'argent pour franchir la
frontière dans quelques heures et puis
ça durait trois semaines dans les
marécages là où il ya les champs de
bataille entre girac élire aujourd'hui
oui et je dois dire que c'est un des
miracles que je suis en face de vous
nous sommes ravis de nous avoir si alors
vous publié chez laffont un livre qui
s'appelle le diamant noir et qui
racontre un peu votre vie tout cette
époque lira que l'arrivée en israël
votre réussite dans le commerce et puis
votre décision finalement un jour de
tout de tout quitter pour servir israël
et vous êtes nommé attaché d'ambassade
en centrafrique avant d'être nommé
ambassadeur ocha avait quelque chose qui
m'intéresse beaucoup parce que j'avais
eu connaissance du projet de herzl
d'installer israël n'ont pas en
palestine mais en ouganda et j'avais
imaginé dans un livre que finalement
qu'est ce qui se serait passé si israël
avait été installée en ouganda alors moi
c'était du roman mais vous comment avez
vous vécu cela est compensé vous de ce
projet je dois dire que dieu merci que
ce projet n'a pas été réalisée et parce
que en ouganda le peuple juif n'avait
aucune racine donc nous serions dans une
situation très difficile alors que dieu
merci nous avons établi notre état dans
un état dans une terre qui nous
appartient avec une longue histoire avec
des racines et lorsque je suis arrivé en
centrafrique j'ai vécu le moment des
pionniers d'israël en afrique nous avons
amené avec nous l'esprit pionnier nous
avons avec amener avec nous les
raccourcis pour le développement nous
étions nous nous sentions comme une
seconde aire de pionnier en israël nous
avons vécu comme les africains je dois
dire que lorsque j'ai décidé de tout
quitter pour aller dans la carrière
diplomatique évidemment on pourrait
penser que c'était une vie en noir avait
pas et puis je me suis retrouvé avec des
chauffeurs
jill dans des jeeps avec un ambassadeur
qui m'accueille en ceinture qui était un
cordon qui servait comme ceinture pas de
fast nous avons et nous nous sommes
installés dans une écurie qui était
transformée en domicile parce que
l'ambassadeur qui était un membre de
quibou tu voulais à implanter l'esprit
pionnier niçois et l'on a fait alors il
ya aussi un autre chose qui vous
particularise si vous êtes le premier
ambassadeur d'israël en france à être
sépharade finalement ça a été quand même
un événement parce que juste là église
ashkénaze qui était ambassadeur d'israël
en france est-ce que ça a été difficile
ce qui paraît votre nomination n'a pas
été sans soulever quelques quelques
problèmes en israël non vous savez je
n'aime pas entamé le problème des
ashkénazes et séfarades d'autant plus
qu'en ce moment en israël il ya vraiment
un fusion très efficace il ya un seul
culture il y a il n'y a pas vraiment de
différence album sylvain bergère numéro
13 ça porte bonheur spécial trois ans
des bains fête de la rose françois
delacroix si les grands bague
cuisse
pères
andrée putman
hal gill andreff yves mozy
floch
jean bousquet philippe starck
culotte
[Musique]
ballon
mollet
nov
jenny phillips tard
dominique issermann
françoise laclau seguin
alcoolisme tatouage
chapeau
décolleté
[Musique]
cuisse
arial de ravenel
oise moulante
[Musique]
en faire l'homme dans les tempos
le chou et madame comme ça
[Musique]
l'arrivée notre ami bonsoir par local ya
sapho jean nouvel bonsoir à tous
en hommage à la soirée jean nouvel à
l'institut du monde arabe cheb kader et
du rail
on a des mots
m
on ne dit pas
et
m
elle
[Musique]
m
ma
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on a mieux
ok vous
allez
m
gfr
alors j'en tue organisé lundi dernier
une soirée à lima comme tu dis à
l'institut du monde arabe comme disent
les les eaux ici couette avec le groupe
reich est clair qu'on vient de voir oui
j ai d ailleurs extraordinaire c'était
bien d'ailleurs n'y a qu'à voir
l'ambiance qu'ils ont réussi à mettre
ici en cinq minutes ouais c'est du
jamais lu une formidable anti devenu la
star de l'architecturé française star
ce marché il m'a dit 'il va faire une
telle sur vous sur une maison pour moi
il m'a dit il ya un truc comme référence
à l'institut du monde arabe tu l'as vu
c'est super
je crois au delà de mon cas personnel
cas ce serait pas mal qui est de temps
en temps des stars dans le maine de
l'architecturé pasquereau bien comme ça
et entraîne une vieille
une vieille image quand même qui est pas
très positive en plus et ionesco qui
nous a pas aidés je crois qu'il est
c'est pire s'il commence par abrupte i
need you architectes externe ça fait
quand même bien de la merde
alors ton style c'est pas en avoir ouais
c'est à dire c'est que tout le monde tu
es nombre des petites choses interdites
genre petite colonne dorique quand on a
un staff et tous ces années c'est plutôt
la non c'est pas tellement fort que les
gens tu fais une synthèse et tu fais des
dessins a prévu d'en faire avoir passé
ça finalement j'essaie de se trouver à
chaque fois les bonnes raisons de faire
plutôt comme si que comme ça là ouais
voilà moi j'ai complètement flashé quand
j'ai vu la clinique de bezons là en le
paquebot d'histoire national de caen ce
disant toi y'a pas longtemps je vais
faire du savoir vivre et alors pourquoi
un pas que vous prêtez et sesat un peu
comme un paquebot on dit que c'est un
paquebot en europe qui disent que c'est
un train qui disent que ça ressemble à
un avion en fait c'est que dès qu'on
utilise des matériaux ou des techniques
de l'époque en particulier de
l'aluminium du verre ça fait référence à
d'autres
ingénieur ou d'autres d'acheter qu'ils
ont utilisés dans des raisons très
précises et dans les domaines qui
étaient un peu plus en avance que la
relecture et on retombe sur les domaines
qui connote ne pas comprendre les choix
d'accord avec toi c'est c'est le truc de
nîmes la nemausus parce que finalement
tu dis moi le logement social je veux
pas le faire comme du sous logement
bourgeois je veux faire autre chose mais
finalement les gens qui habitent à lille
mais toi la place de quelqu'un qui
habite labat et c'était en centre ville
en centre ville à mi match est une jeune
fille tu rencontres un mc oui j'habite à
nemausus le mec qui sait que tu es
pauvre parce que si tu veux ça c'était
ben oui puisque ça ressemble pas et
alors en plus en plus c'est un truc plus
terrible c'est que les deux pièces ils
ont des volets verts en si le mec va
t'attendre en bas de chez toi et que tu
lui dis bonjour à la fenêtre comme ça et
qui voit les volets verts verte à toi
tes parents ils ont de quoi se payer car
je trouve pas ça roulait vers les
vallées versé des pièces
pas de volley-ball et l'histoire me
reste à sélestat en verre non mais
nemausus à faire des logements sociaux
qui avait justement cité hlm se
ressemblent pas à des achats nets chez
toi qui a décidé qu'à partir de là ça
faisait pauvres sam est en
fonctionnement non mais tout le monde
est persuadé que ce sont des logements
de luxe ouais et sont des logements qui
commence par avoir une fois et demie
puis le surface que les autres qui sont
qui ont des terrains seront tous 15
mètres carrés avec des façades qui
souvent entièrement
dessus alors ce qui ferait peut-être
pauvres dans l'esprit de quelques-uns
c'est qu'il ya du l'aluminium du béton
brut du métal galvanisé il n'y a pas de
papier pas il n'y a pas de volée il ya
pas de le faire ne crois pas qu'il n'ya
pas de trop avec les peaux même envie
d'inviter dans des trucs un peu comme
les riches même si c'est moins bien mais
il ya beaucoup de riches qui veulent
habiter là ah bon c'est leur problème on
leur interdit
parlant des concurrents alors piano
rogers beaubourg tu en penses quoi le
plus grand bien le plus grand bien je
trouve ça bien quand même je trouve ça
bien mais je pense que c'est un bâtiment
qui est le témoin exacte de son époque
ce d'avenir il ya environ dix ou quinze
ans la vie et sa vieillesse a bien
vieilli moi j'aime bien les bâtiments
qui sont datés ce que j'espère c'est que
lima c'est un bâtiment des années 80 et
maintenant on montre plus toute la tripe
comme ça à tours et puis au cp1 plus
leur jugement tout ça est beaucoup plus
lisse beaucoup plus tendu un peu comme
maintenant les voitures on ne voit plus
les phares qui sort maintenant on va
payer parce que c'est pareil on voit
plus et clio on voit plus les poutres
tout est complètement lisse tout et ça
ressemble un peu à l'intérieur à un
avion là c'est un tout est gris dans des
symphonies de gris aluminium brossé
c'est quelque chose de plus retenu la
pyramide du louvre la pyramide du louvre
et ce à quoi moi j'aurais pas fait ça je
résume
animaux
pour un milieu tech une sorte de
deux grandes plancher de verre après
lequel on est perdus c'est qu'on en juge
pourquoi mais non est ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est intéressant dans le
lourdes avoir eu déjà l'attitude que
n'en ai pas eu peut-être il ya une
dizaine d'années de faire quelque chose
qui se voit de ne pas de ne plus avoir
ce complexe de l' architecture ancienne
des biens appartenant au sénat on n'a
plus le droit d'y toucher ce que je
trouve très bien au louvre c'est qu'il y
ait un morceau par texture du xxème
siècle au milieu des milieux alors star
que vous avez eu un projet ensemble à un
second travail en son temps en temps on
a failli faire un opéra tokyo et ils
nous prennent ouais vous avez fait un
projet on a fait un projet qui était un
monolithe de granit de 180 m de l'an
passé avait été suspendue sessad avec
des salles en feuilles d'or suspendu
dans une sorte de
fil oui on dit toujours que tel en
thibault filaire temps penses quoi de
beau fils ben ça me gêne déjà comme
définissent comme ça non oui lorsque je
pense c'est que l'attitude par rapport à
l'histoire n'est pas celle que je
partage donc quand je disais je ferai
pas moi de fronton
nos colonnes doriques je m'intéresse
beaucoup plus aux techniques de l'époque
à une image
lié aux sensations
et
et aux émotions de l'autre siècle plutôt
qu aux références
historiques aux grecs battre d'accord
alors imagine maintenant compte leslie
brandt laisse libre à paris qu'est ce
que tu fais comme les jeunes minimes
imagine que j'ai pas le prochain
président celui-ci qui dirige maintenant
vous faites ce que vous voulez vous vous
refais vous soit vous créez un nouveau
monument soit vous en faites un qu'est
ce que tu fais non j'ai fait un projet
qu'il tient beaucoup à coeur n'emploie
défense c'est vrai j'ai eu le deuxième
prix est juste comme ça mais j'ai fait
un projet qui me tient beaucoup à coeur
qui sur le jardin des études reee way
qui est le jardin d'aidé dessiné par le
nôtre qui massacrent et aujourd'hui où
on reprenait tous les thèmes de lenôtre
actualisé avec l'intégration des oeuvres
d'art avec des éclairages la nuit et
faire une sorte de deux jardins de ville
qui soit un coeur de ville qu'ils
puissent vivre deux jours de nuit qu'il
y ait zone par une passerelle or c est
le louvre voilà c'est ça qui serait si
on me disait fait le projet que tu veux
a paris je fais les feelies alors
maintenant le district de tu changerais
rien enregistré un triplement ce trivial
et surtout pas cortier surtout la
confiance au district on s'est connus et
maintenant on va voir des danses
sévillanes comme on les écoute tous les
mardis soirs du street
[Musique]
comme dit philippe corti cole le sud
c'est pas une mode situe le façonne de
faire la fête alors c'est moi général à
prendre au niveau ses bras
[Musique]
pas mon ami nocera grosse et wallen et
la drac rhône tout la vie dans ses bras
on sait
que nous la vivons ces marais à tour la
vuelta
marc ayrault
quant à la famille à nantes les bravos
et vous
m
ou par noël aurait signalé
mardi
[Musique]
alors allez vas-y manuels ont défilé sur
la partie
[Musique]
alors la répartie sur ipad
ok
et messi
[Musique]
m
attendez à rien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle va consacrer guéniot contre ça mais
à l'image
[Musique]
nos salles et à l'élevage
concerné beke a réagi
vanackere
paris areva
[Musique]
m
quant à vannes à son ami a lancé
non
[Musique]
à
oh
[Musique]
des versions qu'elle aie aie l'avivo
caisse et va
elle arrive au festival
m
[Applaudissements]
ils m'ont fait c'est vrai
et la mine au fait c'est la commune en
santé
et comme des pros
[Applaudissements]
m
un mari beltrami tu as toujours fait des
trucs extraordinaires je me souviens
d'un sac en en forme de ticket de métro
un autre fait avec un tapis de sol de
voiture et ça fait d'autres or ils
allaient au bhv acheter le vhb j'ai un
geste que toutes les choses que je
trouvais bien jeu sans savoir que
j'allais en faire des trucs de pêche
pour faire des boucles d'oreilles on
étouffe de pêche des trucs de des
poignées de portes du tout pour les
étagères fatou et puis quand j'arrivais
chez moi je les mettais ensemble et ça
faisait dès lors sa dernière trouvaille
c'est une chemise pour tonton ouais
alors explique nous ça commence à
s'atténuer qu'est ce que tu vas en enfer
ça m'est venue après quoi la chanteuse
accord c'est un bolide est de rendre
hommage à quelqu'un qu'on aimait bien et
comme j'aime bien mitterrand j'ai décidé
de différer sa chemise et j'ai demandé à
des gens célèbres et moi c'est l'air
comme depardieu
j'ai connu
un dating caroline loeb et tous les gens
qu'il aimait bien d'écrire un petit mot
pour lui pas le thème c'était j'aime
tant j'ai très très bien c'est ce que
fait globe la semaine prochaine mais toi
tu l'as fait sur une chemise c'est pas
un peu plus le ballon est ce que je fais
de la mode donc je suis un peu ce que je
sais faire pour dire quelque chose et on
la trouve cette chemise devant la vendre
à jean-paul doute yves à la vigne c'est
pareil et michel klein va j'ai demandé à
des gens qui font aussi de la mode de la
vente parce que je sais pas très bien
comment la diffuser
du coup j'ai pas de boutique est large
et touristes en jeu l'avant labellisé en
mars voici voilà je suis prête merci au
stade paulo bon soir tu fais des photos
sublimes
tu peux nous montrer ce que tu as fait
pour la pochette du disque
c'est très beau et
en effet voilà celle qui vient derrière
la monodie 1 6 1 vous n'êtes pas battus
pour savoir laquelle de réunir devant à
laquelle devait venir derrière si avec
on s'est battu et j'ai eu gain de cause
je voulais c'est d'aimer l'autre c'est
pas gagné oui parce que
j'avais tort l'idée
fait des belles choses comme et merci
olic alia par l'hôtel bally's par luca
lia qui ressemble un petit diable
aujourd'hui dupré mignon il est en
mission dans sa faute a été la première
à faire des mélanges de musique voilà
oui
mélangez coin quoi au départ alors
j'aime est loin d'angers mélanger un peu
de musique orientale et de new wave et
j'aimerais ça l'a mal à me rock new wave
et puis ensuite j'ai vu que finalement
il y avait plein en ce moment je sais
pas s'il ya de la musique est non alors
j'appelle ça a marqué deux logiques
partout et n'importe quand je suis très
très fier oui je suis carrément après
que certains pressé alors carrément et
curieuse deux affaires le lin pierre va
faire comme chez drucker voilà on
attendait quand est ce que tu fais
l'olympia du tout voilà voilà vous savez
tout le monde est d'accord voilà au
décor pas et tu fais des tournées
mondiales alors il paraît que testa roja
pour moi je me méfie quand on dit que
les gens sont star au japon parce que
y'a tellement de chanteurs français qui
ont expliqué qu'ils étaient star au
japon est finalement bon quand on avait
les chiffres c'est quoi une star au
japon non je suis chargé dans un sens ou
pour les japonais en principe la marche
en confiance et gréco
montant etc et parmi les gens jeunes ne
connaissent pas et c'est uniquement
anglo-saxonnes
comme dans beaucoup de pays étrangers
d'ailleurs et puis j'ai un
nintendo gilles agatha qui j'ai pas
éternuer se sont bons c'est ce thème qui
est marié française et qui voulait
absolument montrer il y avait de la
musique d'un processeur est ici avec
budget
et puis il s'est trouvé qu'ils avaient
j'accroche sur moi et on a donc foncer
dessus comme ça je pense que les gens
sont accrochés à une image centre est
graphiste end une fois que c'est pas un
bleu et blanc sans être anglo saxons
c'est de l'art plaisir voilà l'ampleur
comme je te ferai un petit reproche tu
t'es marié qu'un monsieur qui s'appelle
françois nicolau nicolas françois poncet
nicolette du foie c'est quoi la
mexicaine français les français
mais non il à eelv hypocrisie que les
habitudes de travail avec au mexique il
est vrai qu'avec un parfait mais ce cas
là il nous a fait beaucoup de mal du
bien je
laisse un bon roulement guidon mais
c'est pas ça que je te faire des enfants
ce que je trouve si tu sais que bon il
voulait pas se marier à l'église mais
comme toi bon vous saviez pas trop bien
comment faire tout et où vous avez faits
semblent voilà chez nous c'est bien
sinon on a bossé en blanc parce qu'on
trouvait ça on trouvé ça joli les
églises mexicaine et on est rentré à
reculons dans les huit ont été filmés
retour par ces thérapeutiques sacrilège
des valeurs bancaires pense que je sais
mais du curé était d'accord mais pour
les tenir
en plus tu dis ça va
[Musique]
m
ils ont fait l'erreur
il a mis nos blessés va et comment
prendre en compte et non recevoir
et comment s'y prendre
[Applaudissements]
jocelyne à la d'anvers bonsoir fois dans
l'habitude les coeurs à la télé et je
signe tu fais quoi dans la vie toi moi
je suis hôtesse de l'air c'est bien
parce que lui comme ça comme était pas
là souvent à dompter sur quelles lignes
air france met du coup encore pendant
très longtemps être très chic et
d'ailleurs dont beaucoup s'en rend
compte c'est le rêve de là ils
rencontreront cette histoire va au
cinéma on venait dans le pays mais un
petit pays du nord c'est pas le
gravelines et où maintenant il ya dix
mille habitants des problèmes de il
rêvait 5000 et on se connaissait pas et
on s'est rencontrés trompant aux prêts à
bord d'un avion je revienne journée de
porto pourrait arrêter faire la
révolution des oeillets et puis j'ai
aussi des tests sur le bol et commentés
pour la draguer facile évidemment tu
vois les sujets de conversation parce
que je connaissais sa grand mère sa
tante filaments jour de notre mariage
tout le monde se connaissait sauf nous
le déficit n'est pas pour aggraver la
réputation aussi
sérieuses et hôtesses de l'air
c'est pas terrible pour les hôtesses ici
mais non ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
finalement c'est ces mini son métier me
menacer le pays le génial rapprocher
agréable et c'est toujours payé le
village de croix pour plein de gens
alors là tu publies chez édition numéro
un livre qui s'appelle points chauds
4,16 et conflits dans le monde c'est
notre façon à faire comme chez drucker
c'est vraiment plus que c'est un beau
lycée un beau cadeau de noël et c'est
quoi alors alors tu te souviens toi que
j'ai fait l'émission de télé qui
s'appellera jallet qui s'appelait points
chauds alors l'objectif était d'essayer
de reconstituer un puzzle de l'actualité
parce qu'à force de sujets à la télé
d'une minute et trente secondes on finit
par plus savoir qui pourquoi comment
donc l'émission de télé
cette star et puis
les fils de l'éditeur ont dit à leurs
peurs mais tu devrais demander à ce
qu'il fasse un livre alors l'éditeur
nous mouvoir et à ce moment là j'étais
directeur de formation tf1
à 5 minutes pour le faire et quand je
suis parti il m'a rappelée lendemain
maintenant je le fais elle a une magie
non maintenant mais 88 mitterrand est
réélu président la cncl est complètement
bouleversé on revient une sorte de
hautes autorités
le président d'antenne de change
bélie vanier s'en va on te demande de
prendre la direction de l'information
sur la baie d'authie va t'y vas pas
de toute façon dont première chose c'est
vrai qu'un jour je refais de la télé
c'est vrai que si j'en fais c'est pas
forcément comme directeur de
l'information je fais une fois je peux
le faire de voir le public at war non
plus
il faut voir il faut voir les conditions
quand le repreneur dans le privé est
arrivé à tf1 j'ai vu les conditions
finalement je suis parti
alors là je vais encore une fois les
conditions ce que je veux dire c'est que
je suis bien dans mes godasses voilà ta
mère je fais autre chose je viens de
faire un livre qui m'a passionné qui
ressemble un peu à une émission très
payant d'ailleurs main parce que j'ai
mis beaucoup de photos
et j'ai vu que pierce en main par une
émission de télévision donc voilà c'est
une autre étape avant j'avais été grand
reporter pendant cette mi temps avant
j'avais été dans la presse écrite
j'avais fait la radio je considère que
ce que je ne ferai une étape et puis je
suis très ouvert à toutes les aventures
et à toutes les autres étapes mais
forcément certainement quelque part à la
télé en aura d'autres alain tu sais ce
que c'est un new comme un agneau que
explique que vous placer quelqu'un qui
commence dans la vie alors comment on
pouvait pas appeler ça newcomer parce
que c'est emmerdant pour la série t elle
en avait ça wannabe en hommage aux
beatles i wanna be loved by you wanna be
your man en la maintenant on va voir
donc les wannabe de la semaine c'est des
mecs en 30 secondes 40 secondes une
minute pour vendre leur sauce quoi et à
la fin il donne un numéro de téléphone
et si c'est bien les gens les appelle
alors regardez qu'est ce qu'il fait lui
concevoir du chose qui fait patrick
cottencin j'ai 34 ans voilà je suis
sculpteur
j'aimerais montrer ses oeuvres suisses
et l'atelier se trouve ou 14 rue des
haies course en quatrième et dans le
marais le contact c'est le 48 87 23 32
48 87 23 32
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous me reconnaissez à ceux
supportant ou non vous savez damien et
voilà et j'ai fait pour le bon petit
gadget c'est une boule noire simple
design enfin où nous pourrons relever
vous avez ici un scratch et de sous pour
que la population soit quelque chose de
hermétique vous avez le sembler facile
pour les transports avec un clip que
vous pouvez retirer dès que vous le
présenter ici vous avez une petit clapet
pour aller chercher le travail comme ça
vous pouvez avoir une facilité dans la
lecture est regardé plusieurs travaux en
même temps en plus c'est facile pour
quand vous avez des choses et 10
hectares la transparence pas ça facilite
la nexus l'assemblée très très beau j'ai
trop je suis très content et il est à
moins qu il a alors si vous désirez me
contacter par ce que il ya seulement des
jaloux vous faites les 40 c des 77 17 46
voix là et je serais venu recevoir bien
sûr
bonsoir je m'appelle rami captage et 29
ans depuis le début des années 80 je
mémorise en vidéo vous fêtez soirée je
filme également les jeunes créateurs en
mode peinture du sens et performant j'ai
réalisé trois vidéos magazine annuel est
ainsi que des clips et courts métrages
j'aimerais faire des reportages sur les
tournages signer pub ou clic afin de
filmer une équipe au travail si vous
voulez me contacter je pince
actuellement au palace et aurait club en
couverture vidéo vous pouvez également
téléphoner aux 45 35 26 73 à bientôt les
photos mais aussi lit à 8h de firmes et
11es de s'enregistrer
entrées se targuer du tibet
ils vous demandent ils vous donnent un
sujet et ils vous demandent à budget
contacté le local de 46 71 31 alors
imagine que ce soit comme ça soit dans
une boîte par exemple voilà et que tu me
dirai qui tu es
c'est pourquoi je te demande qui tu es à
la sonatel géraldine giraud la fille de
rachida non je suis la fille
l'émotionnel tu l'achète pas si je te le
dirai pas avant je ne dirais pas ça se
connaissait pas on ne dirait pas mais je
te dirais mon prénom c'est surtout que
tu voudrais que je devine quoi tu
voudrais que je t'aime son nom
et qui est la fille d'alain delon
j'en fais mes chansons je
les dis moi moi y'a un truc qui m'étonne
avec toi c'est ton de voix tout en
double page dans paris match entrait
dans les soirées en menant les cocktails
en trois ans et puis alors doublement
toujours ce que tu fais
ça et vous qu'est ce que je fais c'est
mon avis qu'est ce que tu as fait
[Musique]
à 10 heures la sq en ce moment qu'il
parte est il ya une quinzaine de jours
au programme via un clic on va devoir
donner
ça
qui des femmes
mais
[Musique]
alors je t'ai vu dans l'huile sans doute
l'épreuve n'aura plus tard
ce n'est pas ça pour l'argent
perso je veux supplémentaires après son
abandon il peut donner mais pas
forcément ici tous les enfants dont les
parents avaient sous la manche et des
parents fats imagine que si mon père en
avait eu je voudrais demander des moyens
légèrement ne pas savoir mais j'essaie
améliorer tout ça
t'as pas fait ça pour les sous non non
j'ai fait ça parce que c'était de
l'argent aux softs et pas de solution et
que jean russie avec intégré à venir
beaucoup ensuite
peut-être pour casser un peu avec
l'image toujours assuré qu'elle était
d'accord
jean ping
[Musique]
dans la série tout s'est mélangé montpon
messieurs voici sa faut qu'ils chantent
mahmoud
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
vous
non
mon
beau
[Musique]
martin whitmarsh
oh
non
le
mon nom
witt et même bill keller et
montre bien
[Musique]
voilà
il est un
fait
eh bien
[Musique]
l'auteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
kerrigan
shopping
avec moi
tous les mois
le
[Musique]
monde
et tous lindsay là
et tous les ans
la bible
on
tout cela
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
obama
[Musique]
matin
qu'est ce que c'est
[Musique]
on attend
le pas
il
[Musique]
oui
aubry
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
là
[Musique]
m
d oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'ina l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux